and welcome to hannity and tonight we're
tracking multiple major stories
including big news from canada now the
country's pathetic prime minister is
still in hiding as the peaceful trucker
protest gains tons of momentum despite
gofundme trying to steal their donations
or not dispense the money that people
generously gave to them despite a new
injunction making it illegal for people
and truckers and supporters to honk
their horns we'll explain all of it
we'll get to the scene as well tonight
meanwhile back here at home top
democrats they're getting rightfully
slammed over their disgusting mass
hypocrisy but first we're now beginning
week two of the left's all-out uh well
attack on joe rogan
boycott fire cancel
washrooms repeat over the weekend a
far-left group released a montage of
rogan saying the n-word over the years
on his podcast let's state up front this
is simple it's not a hard one it's a
word nobody should use ever rogan
addressed it immediately he apologized
profusely he said the clips were taken
out of context here's what he said
i'm making this video to talk about the
most
regretful and shameful thing that i've
ever had to talk about publicly
there's a video that's out that's a
compilation of me saying the n-word it's
a video that's made of clips taken out
of context of me of 12 years of
conversations on my podcast now i know
that to most people there is no context
where a white person is ever allowed to
say that word never mind publicly on a
podcast and i agree with that now
i haven't said it in years but for a
long time
when i would bring that word up like if
it would come up in conversation instead
instead of saying the n-word i would
just say the word i thought as long as
it was in context people would
understand what i was doing like that
context was
part of the clip we were talking about
red fox how red fox said that word on
television in the 1970s and how times
have changed so much since then or about
how richard pryor used it as one of the
titles of one of his albums
this raises a lot of questions tonight
how will the country the marketplace
respond to comedians so let's say chris
rock for example who used the word a lot
on stage time will tell if rogan had
said nobody should ever use this word
and said the word in that context would
people be as upset should they be now
i've not listened to any of the podcasts
mentioned in the montage but rogan
admits he's wrong said he's embarrassed
he regrets it his apology does sound
sincere kind of like whoopi goldberg's
apology for her comments on the
holocaust well to me it was sincere i
know her well enough over the years i
know she's absolutely not anti-semitic
and my rock-solid support for israel and
the jewish people is well known i
wouldn't tolerate an anti-semite or a
racist but again this is the great thing
about freedom if you don't like any of
these shows you don't have to watch them
you don't like whoopi goldberg you don't
like joe rogan turn the channel no one
can force you to watch sadly with many
on the left all they want to do is
silence cancel boycott and end all
dissent most people also feign outrage
when they're not actually offended
they're using censorship as a political
tool often to cancel conservatives now
think about this joe biden he's the
president of the united states he ran
for president for over a year he's not a
podcast host he's not the co-host on a
talk show and yet he's never ever
apologized for his years of frankly
downright racist rhetoric and actions as
a senator we've told you very few people
ever pay attention didn't even come up
except for kamala harris in one debate
he worked with segregationists he worked
with a former klansman to stop
integration of public schools and busing
he worried that children would go to
public schools that are quote in his
words a racial jungle his mentor in the
u.s senate was a former klansman during
a hearing in the 80s he himself used the
n-word multiple times uncensored while
reading a quote he more recently
proclaimed that you have to have a
slight indian accent if you want to work
at a dunkin donuts or 7-eleven in his
state he also referred to obama as the
quote the first
mainstream
african-american who is articulate and
bright and clean
this is storybook man no other
african-american before uh joe was
articulate bright and clean this is the
first time
he bragged at his home state of delaware
my state's a slave state he said and in
virginia he donned that fake
african-american accent told the crowd
that mitt romney is going to put you all
back in chains biden's son hunter
long-time crack addict frequently used
the n-word in text messages with his
attorneys is there anyone on the left
that was as outraged that the president
of the united states his son
uh and he himself with his racial
history meaning joe is anybody offended
anyone speak out how often did you hear
about it if you're a democrat if your
last name is clinton biden no outrage
from the democratic left there's no
calls for boycotts cancellations or
censoring at all whatsoever if you're a
conservative or god forbid you have the
last name trump i think the reaction we
all know would be very different the
last time i checked the president of the
united states is a lot more powerful
than a podcast host no matter how
popular that host may be
by the way so is the new mayor of new
york city his name is eric adams no
one's calling for his cancelling his
firing his
hit or even of an apology that i've
heard for these comments
every day in the police department i
kicked those crackers ass man i was
unbelievable in the police department
with one of the black colored
enforcement
came a sergeant a lieutenant and the
captain
you know the stories i would rather wear
white all day grow a bed smoke some weed
and leave this stuff alone
really
man you think bro
[Applause]
that wake up every day don't like
themselves they're going to beat me up
the people who
say wins are real black leaders they're
gonna say listen who's eric you know why
does everything he should be made well
negro you run
mayor adams later apologized did he mean
it as with everyone else time will tell
there are now there were no calls for
him to be cancelled in any way there
wasn't even a lot of criticism you know
how far back do we go here we're going
to talk about howard stern in the in the
80s uh what about the times all these
people dressed in blackface on many
occasions said many things that they
wouldn't say today do we need to go back
through the archives of anybody and
everybody that might have said something
that through today's prism is different
i don't think the answer is yes what
about jimmy kimmel madonna quentin
tarantino their use of the m word pulp
fiction in that case what about the
hundreds of songs right now on spotify
that probably degrade women call them
derogatory names are there any other
songs glorifying violence and murder and
drugs they use the n-word to their
credit spotify says they're not
canceling joe rogan at least not not as
of today if they do the growing
streaming platform rumble they've
offered rogan 100 million dollars to
make the switch now whether you like joe
rogan or not there is a good sign that
there is a movement in this country
that's willing to accept the idea of
freedom and turning the channel and not
being forced to listen or watch
something that you find offensive and
that's why i'm so adamant about this why
because
it's a very simple reason nobody can
force you
you get to decide you have full control
of this now not everyone agrees you got
fake news cnn they would love for rogan
to be ripped off the airwaves of course
no one watches cnn and their dear leader
is now long gone and now as uh one guest
told humpty dumpty over the weekend i
would be nervous if i was at cnn after
mr potato heads ouster and according to
the wall street journal multiple hosts
are lashing out humpty is in a panic
putting his resume together in all
likelihood take a look
and you can draw a straight line from
andrew cuomo's downfall to zuckers
it is almost shakespearean
but the people who say we're lacking
journalism
that we've become an all talk channel
that we've run off and we're all
opinions all the time
that jeff zucker led us astray
those people aren't watching cnn
they're not watching cnn
they're watching complaints about cnn on
other channels that don't know what
they're talking about
that's the truth
we lost our leader this week
but we're not going anywhere
so we'll see you back here next week
they're not watching cnn first time he
stumbled on the truth but really what do
you expect from
jeff zucker's stenographer now of course
humpty is not a journalist uh nora's
fake jake news tapper or don lemon
they're all opinion hosts talk show
hosts just like me except i'm honest
they are like me members of the press
for sure they're not fair and balanced
journalists and by the way if you're one
of the few that do watch cnn for any
length of time you'll know it's true
look at jeffrey toobin recently
masturbating on a zoom call in front of
his co-workers
he's not a journalist either
fake news jim acosta who just called a
called virginia soviet style police
state that's journalism that's not an
opinion because they ended mass mandates
yeah not journalism in the daytime more
opinion from other trump hating obsessed
democrats that they say are journalists
they're not they're talk shows they're
members of the press they're talk show
hosts they occasionally do straight news
but they give a lot a lot of opinion
then we got jonah goldberg by the way he
just joined fake news cnn the anti-trump
pundit is now so desperate for a
platform that he joined cnn three years
after tweeting
this meme right there
yikes now we can go on and on and on
straight news has been extinct for a
long time over there all hoes pretty
much now giving their opinion but here's
this thing fake news cnn still pretends
that all of these hosts are non-partisan
journalists
they're not
they're talk show hosts they're giving
their opinion which reminds me of a
famous russian quote we know they are
lying they know that they are lying they
know we know they are lying and we know
they know we know they are lying but
they're still lying
this is fake news cnn now i don't call
for anyone to be fired but if i were
humpty dumpty no i'd probably be
sweating a little more than he usually
does hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else